je suis en rouge et donc je vais à la
galère j'ai décidé le point devant les
embouteillages et des violations dans le
must des familles en vacances ce qu'ils
vont faire leurs courses ou qui plus
simplement vont travailler mais tous
sont unanimes ce moyen de transport est
plutôt apprécié pour inviter l sur le
confort dans le bus c'est votre problème
tout va des congrès tout va bien
celui de poster son ticket et tout va
bien
obama a déclaré samedi que vous êtes
ça va vite il irradie premier avantage
du bus à haut niveau de service des
embouteillages visibles dans les deux
sens entre fort-de-france et le lamentin
notre bus avant sa vitesse de pointe 70
km heure et puis nous retrouvons le
passager avec lequel nous avons échangé
ce que nous ne savions pas c'est que
c'est la première fois qu'il prend ce
but il a tout de suite compris les bons
côtés de ce moyen de transport moins
chez nous un jour je suis toujours voué
au donc ça me permet de voir les
différences les différences truc
soutient qu'il ya de nouveaux os en
voiture on a toujours inscrit sur ce qui
est à côté ce qui est devant est-ce que
c'est confortable oui par rapport à ce
que je connais pour avoir outrepassé ses
compétences
galeria un arrêt important le bus
poursuit son trajet jusqu'à mao le
terminus et de l'autre côté de la gare
des passagers qui attendent direction
fort de france une fois rentrés dans le
véhicule
nous assistons à une scène qui doit
certainement se répéter à longueur de
trajet de passagers qui échangent et
garde le contact pratiquement mono ces
nouvelles a joué dans la joie par
honnête nous ne l'avons nous finirons et
puis collègue l'a dit - avez-vous des
bureaux de gaza zadig est un nouveau né
à bath grâce à toutes ces magouilles des
souvenirs aussi tendues avec l'otan lui
avoue séduisent connaît donc un vif
succès seul bémol il semblerait que 70 %
des passagers voyagent récents titres de
transport